У своїй квартирі, що в містечку Долина,
на Івано-Франківщині
Валерій Зеленчук розмірковує
про долю земельної ділянки
що за триста кілометрів, на Рівненщині
Її успадкувала його 70-річна матір
ще від своєї матері
Сам принцип, що це не нормально
коли в людини є приватна власність
і людина не може нею в повній мірі,
скажем так, розпоряджатися
тому шо не може ні продати,
ні в оренду нормально здати,
за нормальну ціну
бо немає знов-таки законів
Близько 7 мільонів українців володіють
земельними паями
Та займаються сільським господарством одиниці
Для більшості єдиний вихід - здавати землю в оренду за копійки
Валерій каже, за свої два гектари
його матір щорічно отримує до 4 тисяч гривень
Тоді як в Європі середня ціна оренди
в п'ять разів більша
Аби привернути увагу держави
до земельної проблеми
чоловік подав скаргу
до Європейського суду з прав людини
Два роки судової тяганини - і рішення ухвлене
Абсолютна заборона в Україні продажу або будь-якого іншого способу
відчуження земель
сільськогосподарського призначення
мораторій на відчуження
порушує положення конвенції
та не відповідає практиці Європейського суду
Розпаювання понад
двадцяти семи мільйонів гектарів
аграрних земель України відбулося у 90-х роках
Та справжню інвентаризацію досі не провели
власники можуть навіть не знати, де саме їхній пай
Скасування мораторію
не врегульовує також інші питання
хто саме зможе купувати землю - українці чи іноземці
Як вберегти ринок землі
від недобросовісної конкуренції
а отже, які мають бути обмеження для покупця:
50 гектарів чи 150
Всі ці питання породжують в українського суспільства небезпідставні страхи
Можливо саме тому за соціологічним опитуванням
лише 13% українців підтримують
скасування мораторію
А депутати побоюються втратити голоси виборців
та продовжують мораторій
Мораторій - ми розумієм, що це тимчасовий захід
І фермери розуміють, і великі компанії,
і середні, всі розуміють
але фактично у цей тимчасовий захід не відбувається змін до законодавства
тобто воно не вдосконалюється
не відбувається державна політика, яка направлена на тих
хто фактично працює на землі
Замість того щоб створювати законодавчу базу
народні депутати
звинувачують одне одного у бездіяльності
Хоча з 2002 року, часу, коли почав діяти мораторій
і до сьогодні, змінилось чимало урядів
і кожна з фракцій
входила до парламентської більшості
Та законодавства,  яке б регулювало ринок землі, досі немає
Натомість успішно діє інший закон
”Про оренду землі”
Він дозволяє здавати українські чорноземи
в оренду до 50 років
"Мрію", агрохолдинг,
який один там з топових агрохолдингів України
Хто купив? Саудіти!
Китайці володіють землею в Україні
через договір оренди
Зараз існуююча ситуація дозовляє
задешево скупати
корпоративні права на землю
Це коли там, умовно кажучи, у тебе там 20-30 чи 50 років оренди вже підписано
Задешево це дозволяється.
Китайці цим користуються
Мораторій не захищає від китайців
Земельна реформа є важливою умовою
програми співпраці України і МВФ
Закликає до цього і Світовий банк
Та поки земельну проблему традиційно обговорюють у парламенті
лише наприкінці року, коли постає питання про продовження мораторію на наступний рік
Тоді ж під стіни парламенту виходять і аграрії
які бояться, що в умовах беззаконня
мораторій таки скасують
Повинно запрацювати нормальне законодавство
перш за все, повинен наступить мир на нашій землі
і тільки тоді, коли всі питання вирішуються у правовому полі
коли ми досягнемо
до рівня цивілізованого суспільства
лише тоді можна говорити про ринок землі
Абстрактно? Але на сьогоднішній день ці всі умови, які виставлялися, не виконані
Повірте, сьогодні буде не ринок землі
не обіг землі, а прямий дерибан
За ухвалення законів, а не лише скасування мораторію, виступає і Валерій
Він сумнівається, що це скликання
Верховної Ради та уряд
зможуть вирішити проблему
Якби це було перший рік мораторію чи другий навіть
сумніваюсь навіть, що суд би
взяв до розгляду це питання
Ну зрозуміло, тому шо
щоб прийняти закони процедури довгі
і мораторій для того
щоб врегулювати це питання
Але це на протязі десятків років
і рік за роком це йде, а депутати...
зі своєї сторони взагалі нічого не роблять
Чоловік сподівається, що до судів -
і європейських, і українських
почнуть звертатись інші українські пайовики
і через суспільний тиск
політики нарешті почнуть діяти
А поки статистика така
за даними Держгеокадастру
середній вік пайовика — 60 років
а понад майже півтора мільйони
власників паїв померли
так і не дочекавшись права розпоряджатися
повноцінно своєю приватною власністю